hey guys this is the kind of video which
I've never really made before I'm not
really sure if I'll really put it on
YouTube or if it will even be a series
but it's one that I've been wanting to
make for a quite a while it basically
revolves around tips and ideas and my
philosophy behind playing the game and
it's based on many comments that have
been seeing lately your comments that
you know are basically like how do you
make things like this or how do I make a
good coaster please help sadface which
recommends that make me kind of sad
because i don't really know what to do
with them it's hard to come up with a
way to help the community out I think
and I've been trying to find that out
for a while now and while I would like
to make tutorials and it's something
that I've been wanting to make for a
long time - I'm not really sure what to
make tutorials about for one I am not
really sure what people are looking for
in tutorials with kind of subjects and
things of the gameplay people are still
looking for so just in case you are
looking for tutorials and you would like
me to make some tutorials please do
leave your comments in the cone in the
comment description in the comment
section to say like what kind of topics
you want me to make tutorials about and
I'll see if I can actually make some
videos about the most commonly requested
ones but there's another thing that I
want you to keep in mind and that's that
I'm not really a big fan of conventional
tutorials which are like let's make a
German house and this is how you make a
German house and they proceeded to just
make a German house and a lot of people
follow all the steps but that's pretty
much something that you can also do by
watching time-lapse videos or just
copying whatever somebody makes and to
be very honest I don't think it's an
issue if anybody just straight out
copies what I make or what anybody makes
actually think it's a good thing it's
very good practice as long as you don't
share it around with people and say that
it's in your own work because it's a
really good way to get to know how other
people play the game and get to know how
they put things together and how you can
use certain details to make a certain
effect it's basically it's a very good
learning experience I think it's a good
way to improve for your next like own
builds and in that sense I think it's
something that you can
do but I want to you know make some
videos that are a bit more constructive
and in this same vein this is kind of a
solo podcast about something that is
much bigger than all of this that I've
just been wanting to talk about for a
long time and even though this is a very
you know not very well put together
because I'm just randomly chatting here
it's something that I've been thinking
about for years now and it's something
that I think about a lot and what it
comes down to is just my general
approach to playing the game and how I
think you know it's best to approach the
game and get some good results out of it
and there are four things that I want to
talk about in this little solo podcasts
its inspiration motivation expectation
and patience and I think they're all
really important things to make sure you
have if you want to get into playing
games like these for like the aesthetics
making things and if you're into no
making nice things view just into these
games for the sandbox creative kind of
aspects of it there are things that I
struggle with as well and I just want to
share my opinion about and hopefully it
helps some people out so the first thing
something that I've been talking about
in snippets in time lapses but never
really in one place inspiration which
more or less kicks off everything and I
don't think it should be understated or
underestimated in any kind of case
inspiration can be really big and really
important and I don't think many things
or anything really starts off without
inspiration like you always need
something to kick-start your ideas
something that you see that kind of just
gives a spark in your head that gives
you an idea for something else and I
always look for inspiration before I
start making things especially when you
know I'm sort of in a blog period when I
don't really know what to do or I'm just
kind of down don't really come up with
any good ideas and ways to get
inspiration are pretty much endless it
kind of depends on what you're into as
well for theme parks I like to go to
Google Maps actually and just visit
theme parks in
we live see how they're laid out see
what kind of themes they have and
everything it's quite a fun thing to do
as well so I do that quite a lot
especially if you know I'm gonna make a
new park and there were some parks that
are quite similar to it so for instance
right now I'm making a small family park
somewhere in Germany so I just went
through the list of family parks in
Germany that I think it'd be a good
inspiration and a good template to kind
of start working from so looking at
parks like trips drill on Hunter Park
which to set a nice example and give you
some money used to get you going think
other ways to get inspiration that
worked pretty well for me at least our
Google Images literally if you just
google for whatever theme you are
looking for and put wallpaper or concept
art or even the word beautiful or just
put the word itself out there you can
get some amazing results like I've been
looking for a Japanese theme ideas for
about a year now and when I started
doing that I just went to Google Images
and typed Japanese architecture or
Japanese architecture inspiration and
just looked at the results kind of you
know got a few links from that and you
know kind of started building from that
taking ideas from its and looking at
things and getting the idea of yeah I
should build something like that and I
think that's a really important thing of
getting yourself inspired and looking at
things for that you want to you know
look at something and get the idea that
you want to build something like that
except you want to do it in this way
like you want to add your own touch to
it in a certain way and that's how I
look at many of these things now some
interesting sources of inspiration for
me are YouTube videos of many different
kinds for theme parks it's watching
theme park review videos they've got
POVs of virtually any coaster on the
planet out there very good way if you're
looking for inspiration on coaster
layouts and an idea of how courses run
exactly because if you're looking for
like the very concrete details and
characteristics of rollercoasters you
can just find those on Wikipedia the
Wikipedia page rollercoaster elements
and the wikipedia pages for the roller
coaster manufacturers are really good
ways to get you along but inspiration
for rides and an and a more nuanced idea
of how rights run I think mostly comes
out of watching videos of them and
actually seeing them in action and seem
like the very small touches that they
have so yeah I do that quite a bit as
well
then there's also obviously watching you
videos of other people playing the game
and the same goes for images a lot of
the inspiration is also just from other
people playing planet coaster and I
cannot stress this enough even for me
watching other people play planet
coaster is just a big inspiration not
just because it kind of makes me want to
play planet coaster as well which I
guess is more into motivation side of
things but also because you can get some
ideas from it I think communities like
these are so great because they're not
necessarily competitive they're very
supportive everybody takes ideas and
little tips and tricks and ways to you
know get better at the game from each
other like someone discovers this one
bug using which you can make a new kind
of scenery and everybody just kind of
spreads that along and soon everybody
knows of it and starts building of it
and I think that's how communities like
this move forward and how like everybody
in the community and a general level
gets better and it's why I still take a
lot of inspiration from what other
people build which if I definitely see
in some of my builds as well and just
watching videos of other people no
matter how good you think they're builds
are you shouldn't see them as ways to
demotivate you because they're so much
better than what you think your stuff is
because you're always your own biggest
critic and I think you should always
view other people's things as
inspiration instead of letting it
demotivate you because you think you can
never reach that kind of level because
you can and not to mention you want to
you know build on what they've done but
at your own touch to it as well and
those are the biggest inspirations for
me generally I also actually like to go
back to other times
rollercoaster tycoon 3 coasters and
parks still are a big inspiration for me
if you've played rollercoaster tycoon
it may very well be the what like a
second two pikes have been shared along
the forums of roller coaster Cantu
there's some really amazing stuff in
there as well and you know just watching
the things that other people have built
in any kind of game can get you going
with some sort of inspiration now when
it comes to motivation and this one's a
little bit harder I would say the
difference between them is not that big
actually see many discussions about like
what the exact difference between them
is but for me personally it's that
inspiration is what gives me an idea of
what I want to do it gets me going when
I don't really have an idea of what I
want to do but I still want to do
something and motivation for me is that
idea that I want to do something like
some sometimes I have an idea I'm
inspired to do something but I don't
really have much motivation for it and
sometimes I kind of feel like I want to
make something but it just doesn't
really happen that well and I think many
people can you know share this feeling
but generally speaking I think the more
inspired you are the more you're also
motivated to make some things but I'll
come back to this later on because I
think both inspiration and expectation
and you know having patience as well
they all turn into motivation think the
most important points for motivation is
that you have a certain goal that you
want to strive toward it can be the
inspiration that you've seen from
something else that you want to make
something like that it can be be
planning or the ideas that you wanna you
wanna make and it can be anything else
like just you know getting yourself to
do something in this game and actually
achieving something in which case a very
strange way for myself to sometimes get
motivation is sometimes I just find
myself going you know through social
media all the time and not really
achieving anything and then it's two
hours later and I'm still browsing my
Facebook feed and I'm like yeah what the
hell did I just do I just wasted all
that time and
you know while it seems like sometimes
I'm not really motivated to play planet
coach because I try to avoid it as much
as I can at some periods of time when
actually get to it when I actually get
the motivation and start doing it it
just feels better than wasting my time
on Facebook feeds and you know actually
building something it feels bit more
like you're actually doing something
even though just playing a game and
that's how it's more or less always felt
for me since playing these games who
knows little but yeah that's why I
decided recently to shut down my
internet sometimes when I'm playing the
game just completely shut it down and
ignore any kind of social medium and
anybody who's trying to talk for me talk
with me because now I'm playing planet
coaster for a few hours and I think
sometimes that's just quite motivating
for me personally but then again I also
have to say you know motivation is quite
a personal thing like what gets you
motivated kind of depends really depends
on what you're looking toward and what
you want to achieve oh if that sounds
really official you know it's just a
game in the end but for me personally I
think it's kind of important because I
don't want to push myself too much but I
do find that when I'm motivated to
actually do something even though it
seemed at first that I didn't want to
play planet coaster
it just is more fun in the end than
whatever I was doing to procrastinate
though procrastination is a completely
different topic that I won't get into in
this video because it's a terrible thing
that I don't want to remind myself of
again anyway moving on to expectation
which really ties into motivation for me
personally because well not just for me
personally I think it's a it's ties into
motivation quite well and more than
people normally think of because one
thing that gets me going that gets me
motivated is having an idea of what I
want something to look like like I've
got a general planning or you know this
is gonna be a village it's gonna look
this way and I want it to be exactly
this way there's gonna be the Town Hall
over here that's gonna be Church over
here and it's gonna look like this and
it's gonna be awesome and if you have
that kind of expectation of what you
want to do if you have a general idea
I'm planning
of what you're going to do it's much
easier to get that motivation because
you've got something to look forward to
like every single wall that you build
isn't just a random wall in the middle
of nowhere but this is gonna sound so
cheesy but it's it's a wall that you let
you place that is one step closer to
making what you are trying to make a
reality it's once more closer to making
that alpine village a reality within the
game and actually finishing it and for
me at least that's a much bigger push
than just randomly building without a
plan and this is why for me and I think
this would go for many other people
because it's something of a bit of a
mistake that I see many people make that
they just open the game and do whatever
and just kind of mess with things and
just keep going now this doesn't look
good this isn't look good I don't wanna
make this what am I even doing here and
after about an hour you haven't really
achieved anything and you just kept
removing your own things I've had this
way too many times myself and just it
feels really useless and not really
motivating and for that reason having an
idea in your hand you don't really have
to sketch it out there don't have to be
like sketch up models just to model out
what you want to make it's just a game
but just having an idea of what you want
to make which often sparks from the
inspiration that you've got as well just
having an idea of I'm gonna make this in
this way helps to get me motivated at
least and I think this would go for many
people it's a lot more motivating in any
case than having no idea what you're
doing and just kind of randomly doing
things and in the end it often looks a
bit better if you've planned things
ahead a little bit as well if you've got
an idea of what you want to make
somewhere it and it most likely ends up
being a little less incoherent and you
can always just tweak with things a
little bit later
like once you are done making what you
were planning to make and you think now
this isn't exactly looking like I was
hoping to because it will never look the
way that you were hoping to you can
always tweak some things and look at
them afterwards but you've already got
most of their progress done and I think
that's quite important for that as well
so yeah for me
I think this would go for many other
people having an idea in your head of
what you want to make really helps me
going not just in terms of you know
keeping me building and interested in
actually working on what I'm building
but also it just makes the final results
more clear and well put together in many
of my cases and it just makes the game
more fun to play and yeah you will also
need some patience for it which is why I
wanted to talk about that for a second
as well I kept many questions about like
how I can even stand to play games like
this for four hours in a row and just
keep going with it then I was just about
to say that in day out but that's Dutch
saying that's terrible
but yeah how I keep going on like 24/7
playing games like this truth be told I
don't really I am pretty sure that there
are many people who do have that
patience but there are just certain ways
that you kinda have to get yourself
through it with I think sometimes if
you're really caught in that stream of
yes I'm gonna make this I'm gonna make
this happen you can play for hours on
end and just keep going without any
other real thing that's stimulating you
to do so but in many cases I think for
me personally because I'm not that's
patience it's nice to have something
aside that is also quite enjoyable so I
like to play the game while you know I'm
either playing with people though I
don't really do that as often with time
lapses I love playing the game while
listening to some good music for me this
is really important the music is
everything but you can also you know
take some breaks rarely any of my time
lapses are one single time lapse there's
sometimes recorded over multiple days
definitely multiple sessions on a day
and there's a bit of just well fun
playing around between these time lapses
as well it's definitely not just keep on
playing the game until you know I've got
that video out I think if you've got
something in the background like music
or just talking with people it can be
really relaxing kind of game to play and
that's what I do like about games like
these I think they're barely even games
it's just very
same sort of creative fun it's it's a
lot like drawing or making music I think
it's it's at least more comparable to
that than playing no classic multiplayer
games or what is the mainstream idea of
games and that's why I think you know
patience doesn't look as bad because
it's a relaxing kind of experience in
the end and I do want to you know tie
patients back into the fact that you
kind of want to be motivated as well if
you're motivated you can definitely just
keep on playing games like these hours
on end and if you've got an idea of what
you want to make it's a lot less hard
it's a lot less tough to sit behind the
computer for hours and trying to make
that because you're I don't know I don't
know if too many other people feel this
but you're you're really you feel
motivated to make that thing happen and
if in the end it still doesn't really
work out I think it always works to just
come back to looking for sources of
inspiration just browse the forums go on
YouTube or talk with some people and
check out some awesome things that other
people have made can always get you
going at any point in time and if none
of those things work you can always
close the damn game and play something
else and just have fun because that's
the most important thing in the end but
yeah I think a good way to sum it up is
in general just find what you're looking
for and that should be your goal to
reach if you're playing the game that's
how I get through a lot of it that's you
know inspiration is what helps me to
find what I'm looking for and if I found
it I've got a love like an expectation
of what I want to do which motivates me
to keep going and at that point patience
isn't really too big of an issue anymore
that's how it generally approached the
game and it also kind of makes the game
a bit more fun in the process for me as
well and yeah that is how I look at it
mostly there are a couple of other small
things that I want to fit into this
video just to get going for a little bit
longer that I do want to talk about and
if they kind of refer to general tips
that I want to give and that this seems
like a good opportunity to give in as
well whenever you're building anything
make sure you've got an idea of
what you want to make first this doesn't
just go for park layouts but it also
goes for smaller things it just gets you
most creative and I think it's also what
it gets most of the outside-the-box
thinking I've talked about it a bit
before but it's how I approach much of
how I built my things so to give an
example actually the very infamous
chimney pillars in grizzly Valley was
something that was frowned upon because
how does anyone even get the idea to use
chimneys as a pillars but it's an idea
that more or less stemmed from the fact
that I knew what I wanted to make and I
was looking for ways to make that happen
I knew that I wanted to make pillars and
I was just scrolling through the icons
in the game to see what it would
actually work to make those pillars and
the chimney just turned out to be the
thing that worked most and this is a
mindset that I think works a lot better
than looking at the pieces in the game
and seeing what you can make with it I
think I can summarize it as the best
nine sets you have is to think of what
you want to make then look at the pieces
in the game to see how you can make it
instead of looking at the pieces in the
game and see what you can make out of it
because the latter will just keep you
thinking inside the box it'll make you
look at a window and think right this is
a window I'm gonna put this over my
building here and here and here and
that's how it's gonna work because
that's how it's supposed to work but if
you have the mindset of I'm gonna build
a Roman temple I don't give a [ __ ] if
none of these pieces are actually meant
to make a Roman temple with it I'm just
gonna look at the pieces and see if they
can fit into my plan and then if they do
you can find some like interesting way
to fit them into that plan I think it's
just a nice way to get more
out-of-the-box thinking going to try
with different themes of the with the
pieces in the game and just overall get
more unique and creative things out of
it it's a lot more fun for me personally
as well because don't you so rigidly
have to follow where the game gives you
it's more about breaking what the game
has and seeing what you can actually do
with the game though I wouldn't
especially recommend trying to make
roofs out of doors it's the idea that
counts there are many different uses for
many different
in the game and will never ever find all
of the uses for all the objects but it's
a lot of fun to just find new little
tricks and ways to use objects in ways
that they're not really meant to and
just keep building on that I think
that's a good way to improve your
building as well if you compare my
current building to what I was making in
grizzly Valley episode 1 like regardless
of whether you think what I build is
good I think you can already see that in
others huge leaps forward in using
certain pieces and it all just kind of
sticks together because in the end and
this is something that I cannot you know
ignore and something that I do have to
say as much of cliche as it is
experience and practice are a lot and I
didn't talk about them in this video
because well they seem kind of
self-explanatory but they are really a
lot and it's it's through this that you
just kind of get better at the game and
I think just personally a good way to
get this to actually let the experience
help you out and get better over time is
to look at the game exactly the way that
I do though I'm obviously always open
for other feedback on this or other
people's comments or how other people
look at the game and play the game and
enjoy the game so I'm definitely up for
some discussion in the comment section
as well but these are just my thoughts
and it's so yeah go get that experience
because experience always counts no
matter how shitty whatever it is that
you're making you at least made
something and it will make everything
that you make from that point onward at
least a little bit better even if you
remove whatever you were working on it's
always progress and it's never a waste
of time and also mention just to bring
out my favorite quote of all time time
you enjoy wasting isn't waste of time
and neither is any kind of time that
you're just doing whatever in a game
like this waste of time because whatever
you're doing you always get better and
the things you'll do in the future just
because it'll build on it anyway this
was my little solo podcast of looking
too deep into games with silver ATS
thank you for listening and if you want
to have more stupidly deep
readings into video games with silver
ads make sure to leave the comments and
in all seriousness though I'm not really
sure if I'm gonna do this much more
often in the future but if you do
appreciate it some feedback would be
awesome Don the other hand if you think
this is totally stupid that's cool too
and you can always leave a comment about
what you kind of do want my videos to
look like but yeah thanks for watching
in any case whether you hate or love
this video and I hope to see you guys in
the next video whatever it'll be